Now, let's run the model
by clicking the green arrow
located above the tool palette.
When Alteryx finishes
running the workflow,
click the OK button to see the results.
Click on the browse tool to
see the configuration panel,
which will show the output
report of the linear regression.
To open the report in a new window,
click on the drop down menu at the top
of the configuration panel, and
select New Window (All Records).
Now we can easily read
the report in detail.
The second table down,
labeled coefficients, has the values
that correspond with the B0, B1, and
B2 variables in the standard
equation we just showed.
These are listed in
the column labeled estimates.
The intercept is the value of B0,
and the rest of the coefficients have
the labels of the actual variables
that we will need to match
up with the coefficients.